bella bella qualcuno vuole un po di
estati basta bella a tutti i ragazzi ma
se come marco accorto specchio c'avevo
il mezzo
giuro mi ero dimenticato di alzare
completamente cosa volevo far vedere in
questo video quanto sono carino coi
baffi sembra un narcotrafficante
colombiano però non si vedono perché le
luci ma li nascondono è proprio vero che
barbara d'urso in realtà non è barbara
d'urso però avere iniziamo con michael
mauer è andato troppo bene il primo
episodio di ai dell'opera loro tetto
vabbè faccia un altro mamma mi ha fatto
milioni di views mi ha raccontato adobe
di parenti a volte ho fatto anche un bel
record sono stato molto bravo non sarà
anche il quadro appare un punteggio
molto simile vediamo cosa abbiamo la
modalità beat the clock che non l'ho mai
fatta e la farò adesso per la prima
volta per niente ai all'over però a
tempo ai 10 secondi per ogni immagine
per capire quale delle due è più famosa
quindi vediamo che cosa esce fuori è
molto adrenalinico quindi devo partire
subito che i tre due uno via allora tra
giudaismo e itunes
credo che itunes sia quella presa meglio
credo mai perfetto 7 milioni e mezzo
col tempo è un casino itunes o maldive
itunes perfetto anche così va bene
maldive o musei
non lo so ma se come manco lui riesce a
separarle quelle acque secondo me come
siamo messi comunque maldive fantastico
josè alle maldive invece era una combo
incredibile museo vietnam secondo me
vietnam e più googlato di moser
fantastico più delle mal día no come le
maldive trapianto di capelli quello che
non devo fare io ho vietnam e vietnam
bike
abbasso i pelati pargo ne ha di meno
mamma mia ragazzi vigile non come la
madonna ma veramente ma comunque beat
the clock mi mette un ansia ragazzi
ragazzi facciamo la modalità normale
perché questa non so proprio capace
classic o allora rimozione di capelli
laser
ok abroad church di emozioni i capelli
ragazzi io vado a mangiare solo che
questo vi sia piaciuto già facciamo a
partire bene porco demonio in un video
dove verranno di volta sono andato
benissimo
organico più 31 c'è dobbiamo fare allora
il test dei marshmallow non so cosa sia
boris becker boris becker poi
rispecchiare o narcotici anonimi e tipo
peggio dagli alcolisti anonimi sono i
narcotici che nessuno a faccia fuga dei
drogati
devo meditare ma ci siamo ragazze lo
prometto stavolta ce la faccio
31 è solo un numero facciamo tende o
tracking trafficking trafficking o
amazon allora secondo voi ragazzi amazon
c'è solo quelle 60 70 milioni di dice a
non siano di più
azzardo 146 milioni sto azzardando
button mi sai che io ho azzardato
tantissime ci sono dato comunque
lontanissimo allora amazon o qualsiasi
altra cosa che posso anche non leggere
tanto e meno credo amazon porca vacca un
jolly amazon missing persons lawrence
taylor il famosissimo non sapevo facesse
anche football americano credo
l'irreprensibile loro è stato perfetto
allora 4 madonna mi sono algeri scotti
dottor scotti lawrence taylor o uno che
assomiglia a gerry scotti quello che il
mio agente di scatto perfetto sbagliato
ho schiacciato giorno mentre ci vedi che
ogni tanto devo morire e me lo merito
nina guarda non c'è verso di vivere io
ancora dopo tutti questi anni non ho
capito cosa c'entra il tipo dietro però
va bene riscaldamento fatto hhh non so
nemmeno se alcuni di voi lo conoscono
però io io l'ho sputava acqua che era un
piacere alla bottiglia
beh non si è visto niente perché la luce
ha tolto completamente l'acqua non mi
riusciva bene è bryan adams di più
cacciatore o bryan adams il cacciatore
secondo me c'è un pò di meno
mamma mia pianse sheldon e a sheldon e
del sonno edizione come non conosce lo
sporco demonio sporco allora serio serio
serio queste quella vera dubai o ac
milan credo mamma mia
milan in vetta secondo me tu vai
mamma mia che rischio milan o polacchi
ala polacchi a meno perché ti piace
signora polacca o prese su guardi più
come di meno come me no ragazzi oggi non
c'è oggi dopo umane obiettivo di oggi
arrivano a 5 di più ok l'obiettivo
cinque ragazzi di meno non sono anche
presto leggendo però mammamia almeno a 5
parco di tv ok famine meno l'amen coesa
cosa di più alcolisti anonimi di meno
mamma mia se arrivati a cinque ragazzi
che a obiettivo prossimo dieci under 20
migliori 13 lo sapevo da meno jackson
five meno immagino non crei mamma mia in
sé ricarica più nessuno i jackson five
eurovision di più
mamma mia ragazzi stavolta siamo andati
via almeno 10 almeno dieci dizionario di
più
mammamia meno male che la gente
analfabeta 10 ok ma è l'obiettivo di
giornata la via raggiunto basta adesso
posso anche smettere avanti per inerzia
prove di meno quello dopo gli si può
prescindere room idraulico idraulico di
pv idraulico di tutti si trovano tutti
pillole per la dieta meno spero
mamma mia atlanta falcons di più
immagino che ci siano più di 74 mila
persone solo in questo stadio quindi più
gli ho detto falcons grandissimi stimo
sacco giocate a edward snyder è finito
sulla sulla rivista wired quindi
immagino che un po di fama c'è la fiat e
no ti prego non essere così famoso mamma
mia oh
cr tette devo capire un secondo a quanto
possa arrivare perchè i ragazzi in
questo momento sia dzeko cristiano che
avrà di più
meta record e l'ho fatto devo fare di
nuovo logo appena fatto non ha però mai
una band e superiamo la metà del record
cristiano almeno 3 milioni
mammamia cristiano cristiano o algebra
credo che cristiano sia molto ricercato
della geografia per capire chi la
capisce l'algebra maledizione algebra o
linkedin linkedin siamo più o meno 20
milioni 37 va bene xfactor ragazzi
secondo me c a quei 7 8 milioni in mano
e di meno scherzo 5 milioni ma sarai
sempre in difficoltà ma non con link di
quindi meno solo mamma mia mamma mia
bene considerando che cos'è il ranking
mondiale neanche italia veniva xfactor o
potala palace per quanto xfactor sia
basso secondo me potrà la palace o meno
[Musica]
mamma mia ragazzi ma 20 hoc è il
silenzio degli innocenti
prego mamma mia ragazzi incredibile 21
non ce la farò mai di meno 22 russell
brand da il marito di katy perry è
giusto di più dai ti prego russell brand
mammamia meno male se mai dovesse aprire
un suo brand è facilissimo trovare nome
russell invitano i giochi che faccio io
però non so quanto la categoria in di
possa essere cercata più di russell
brand secondo me di meno ammazzatemi
sanremo ti prego che forza mamma mia
ragazzi in di o sorveglianza di massa
meno ma tuona rega 25 sta arrivando al
record violino di più dai a prescindere
perfetto dei griffin di più perfetto va
bene i griffin 27 la greco del i e ii
paragliding di meno va bene lo fate la
vostra paragliding mi sono creato
addosso tanti video pizza di più di ttp
peter più la pizza to catch the hottie
cioè solo a napoli cercheranno di più
che che paragliding mamma mia la pizza
dai che siamo a due jaguar e type meno a
prescindere
raga l'ultimo per eguagliare il record
non è un paese per vecchi
fa benissimo il record eguagliato regalo
devo superare casablanca meno e me ne
vado
ti prego fa che si è cercato di meno ti
prego no
raga 31 e il massimo non si può andare
oltre
mamma mia come ragazzi che sono fatti un
bacio così per arrivare a 31 sbagliato
l'ultimo badoer o record o tre ori fatto
il record come se è come se gli usa in
volta invece di fare regole ogni volta
ricorre sempre lo stesso che cazzo stai
dicendo
porca vacca che partita che parcheggia
rosicky incredibile mamma mia ho rifatto
il record mio che era tanto o 31 il suo
gioco incredibile però assicuro loro
infatto pax e non so neanche come mamma
mi ha sbagliato il 31esimo che sfiga
incredibile proprio sfiga sulle 8 in fa
google areva che qua è proprio
incredibile però i video sia piaciuto ha
lasciato un bel commento mi piace mi
sono piaciuti schede vie schiacciate
anche la campanella
con articoli video ci vediamo un pò
seguito di riker noir dove tanto
chissenefrega se ci va più o meno tanto
non si vedono
magari non mi mettono a canotta che non
sono hhh che dite ci vediamo l'anno
prossimo video ragazzi
[Musica]